Okay, Diocora.
So I do want to play a Jebaba London game.
Unfortunately, yesterday, or the last
speedrun game where I tried to do that,
my opponent played g6, so we ended up
transposing to a modern with e4 here.
Hopefully we get an opportunity to play
the Jebaba, and we will.
And we will.
We play the Jebaba London.
Hopefully I don't make a fool of myself.
a6 is one of the more common moves, I
would say, along with e6 and Bf5.
It's like the main trifecta.
I almost put g6 in a separate category
because it's a completely different
type of position that you get.
The lines a6, e6, Bf5, and to a certain
extent c6 all lead to pretty similar
positions, which the kind of
commonality is that the Jebaba London
appears very innocuous.
It doesn't appear all that dangerous.
It doesn't seem like an attacking
opening, but all of that is an illusion.
It's actually a very, very aggressive
system, and a lot of people get in
trouble because they don't realize how
vast White's attacking potential is.
So we respond with e3.
This is a move that you always make in
the Jebaba, and c5 is already a
mistake, right?
Another example of how tricky the
Jebaba London is, c5 is an attempt to
punish us for developing our knight to
c3, because in the London system, the
traditional London, when you face the
move c5, you typically respond with c3.
You build the pawn triangle so that d4
is well defended, but the great thing
about putting the knight on c3 is that
you're exerting immediate pressure on
the d5 pawn.
That means that there is a move to play
here that you don't often play in the
traditional London, and the reason this
move makes sense here is because after
this move, the pressure on d5
intensifies, and it makes it harder for
Black to win back the pawn.
Of course, I'm implying that the move
is d take c5, and it is surprisingly
problematic for Black to win back this
pawn without falling behind and developing.
Knight c6 is the most common response,
and you may think that the automatic
response to that is knight to f3.
This is where getting the course yields
a lot of benefits.
Knight f3 is not the correct move here,
even though it's by far the most common
move online.
The correct move is a3.
Now, the idea of a3 should be very
obvious to everybody.
We want to play b4 and secure the pawn
on c5, but the flaw inherent in this
move seems to be that Black plays e5,
grabs control of the center, and then
wins the pawn on c5 with interest, but
there is a catch.
Rather than meekly dropping back to g3,
we put the bishop on g5, and now the
power of our knight development really
shines through.
We're threatening the very simple
bishop takes f6 and knight takes d5,
which would knock out a key central
pawn and retain our material advantage.
Black has to waste the tempo playing
bishop e6.
What does this give us the opportunity
to do?
Well, this gives us the opportunity now
to secure the c5 pawn with a move b4,
and that's why we played a3.
White is up a pawn for no compensation.
Okay, now we're exiting the opening
stage, and we're entering the middle
game stage, and we have to be accurate.
So because we spent a couple of tempi
crafting our pawn structure on the
queen side, we have fallen behind in
development a little bit, so we need to
remedy that.
So the obvious move would be knight to f3.
Another typical idea in these lines is
to transfer the knight from c3 to b6.
So knight a4 is a move that you see
very often in this line.
I don't see the rush.
I don't see the need to do that immediately.
We'll have to check the course
afterward to make sure I'm getting the
move order right, but I'm pretty sure
that the move is knight to f3.
Black typically castles, and we
continue our development not with
bishop to d3.
That walks right into the fork, but the
bishop is developed more modestly to e2.
That's it.
We're up a full pawn, and more
importantly, it's not just any pawn.
This pawn makes it difficult for Black
to breathe, right?
It's just controlling squares that
Black would like to use to get his
pieces into the game more efficiently.
A lot of people go queen d7 in a
position like this.
Then the effectiveness of knight a4 is increased.
Hopefully you see why, because once the
knight hits b6, that's actually a fork.
At the very least, it'll come with tempo.
So I would say that the compensation is
very limited, because just having more
pawns in the center does not yield compensation.
There's a question in the chat from
Peculiar Estate.
Would you really say there's no compensation?
Black is better center and fairly
classical development.
So we also have classical development, right?
The pieces are actually developed very similarly.
If you compare the placement of the
knights, the placement of these two
bishops, basically development is symmetrical.
The only big difference is that Black
has more pawns in the center.
But both of these pawns are also liabilities.
We're attacking and pressuring both
pawns with our knights.
Our pawn on e3 is doing the job.
It's restricting the mobility of
Black's pawns.
It's making the move d4 a lot less
dangerous than it otherwise would be.
It's like a speed bump, right?
That's not really allowing the card to accelerate.
If Black plays d4, then we would likely
snap off the pawn.
We would trade once, and then we would
garner the e4 square for our knight by
first taking on f6, then sticking our
knight in the center on e4.
Queen e8.
I mean, that is a tricky move.
It sets a trap that I'm seeing through already.
The trap that it sets is if bishop
takes f6, bishop takes f6, knight takes
d5, what you should notice is the
alignment of Black's bishop and white's
rook in the corner.
So Black has this move, e4, but not
immediately, because immediately we
would take the bishop on f6.
The problem is Black first takes on d5,
then plays e4.
That's a discovered attack against the knight.
We do have knight d4 in that position,
but if you keep calculating, Black can
take on d4 and then finally play rook
d8 and win the d4 pawn back with interest.
I'm not interested in these kinds of
tactics because we're simply up a pawn.
Let's proceed simply, and I will show
this over the board after the game, so
don't worry.
Okay, there's no reason for us not to castle.
Clearly our opponent wants to put a
rook on d8 and x -ray our queen and
maybe prepare the move d4.
No, knight e4.
Okay, did I blunder?
I might have blundered.
Whoa.
What is knight e4?
I did blunder this move.
Oh my gosh.
Wow, queen e8 is unbelievable, and the
idea is knight e4.
I didn't see that.
I didn't see that at all.
That is not in the course, needless to say.
Knight takes e4, de, bishop e7.
The idea is ef.
I mean, we're not worse.
I think position is equal.
Position is equal, but that's brilliant
by our opponent, and I'm learning new
things about the line.
So basically, what did I miss?
If the queen was still on d8, then we
would be able to take the bishop on e7,
and we would be attacking the queen, so
Black would have to spend that tempo
recapturing the bishop.
Now we can't do that, so while I still
have to take on e7, White, Black now
takes on f3.
I have to take the rook.
Black takes.
We take, and at the end of the day, we
get two pawns and a rook for two minor
pieces, so we're still—I would probably
prefer White here, but definitely, I
should have seen that.
Still, I think White is doing
completely fine.
Now, when you have a rook against two
pieces, we haven't had too many of
these games in the speedrun, so I think
it's a good thing.
The evaluation of a rook for two pieces
type situations depends primarily on
the relative activity of the rook
versus the minor pieces.
So if you're the side of the rook or
the two rooks, you have to aim for
total rook activity, ASAP.
So in this case, the move is a no -brainer.
We need to put something on d1.
That's the only open file.
I propose that we put the f -rook on d1
so that the rook on a1 kind of
supervised some of these queenside pawns.
Like if Black plays a5 or something,
it's a good idea, I think, to keep one
of the rooks on the queenside for the
time being.
I'm also eyeing the juicy d6 square for
our rook.
We can stick a rook on d6, and we can
use that as an anchor point and then
double rooks on the d -file.
Still, I think White is doing
completely fine here.
After the game, we'll check exactly
where I went wrong.
I mean, castles is kind of a mini
blunder, but I'm just stunned by this
idea, Qe8 and Nd4.
Incredible.
So still, I think White is doing fine here.
Yeah, rook d6 is ultimately the idea.
Suddenly, our opponent is finally
thinking, which has been pretty rare
thus far.
I actually think Black's position is
hard to play, partially because the
knight on c6 is fully restricted.
We're controlling d4, we're controlling b4.
The bishop on e6 is fine, but it has no
jumping off points.
Yeah, it's not as much of a blunder as
I thought.
It was sort of a visceral reaction.
I thought it was a blunder, but now
when I look at this position, I like
White a lot.
I think if Black handles this well, it
should be closer to equal.
The rook trade is probably good for us.
As a general rule of thumb, and this is
very general, if there's a situation
two rooks versus two minor pieces in a
rook, a trade of a pair of rooks favors
the side with the rook.
A lot of situations where it's pure
rook versus two minor pieces, and there
are no other pieces on the board, the
rook often dominates simply because the
rook has long range ability, and the
bishop and the knight's long range
ability to ferry it from side to side
is restricted.
The rook often trampolines from one
side of the board to the other and wins
a bunch of pawns because the minor
pieces are incompetent at defending weaknesses.
I think this is an excellent move that
our opponent just played because this
opens up a square for the knight.
Yeah, this is not going to be an easy game.
I can already sense that.
Oh wow, rook d6, knight e5, rook d1,
there's bishop g4, okay.
I think we should start by sticking the
rook on d6.
This is kind of something that we can
just sort of do, but after knight e5,
assuming that that's what our opponent
wants, we have to think a little bit.
Yeah, d -o -koro is very strong.
Queen e7, okay.
So, well, in the absence of all things
held equal, our next move would be rook
a to d1.
I think that's what we should do.
Is there any tactical issue with that?
No.
Queen g5, yes.
This is actually very, very good play
by black.
This is exactly how I think black
should play this.
So maybe it's a good idea to make it
difficult for black to play queen to g5.
So the move queen to h5 comes to mind,
but then black can stick the queen on
f6 and infiltrate b2.
Actually, I have some tricks in mind.
So let's go queen h5, and the point of
queen h5, I'm stopping queen g5.
And the reason I'm scared of queen g5
is because it aims at the g2 pawn, and
black has these annoying threats like
bishop h3 and bishop g4 to f3.
Now maybe it wasn't as dangerous as I
made it out to be, but I'm trying to
kind of jostle for good spots for our pieces.
I'm trying to make it difficult for our
opponent to coordinate as much as
possible using what we have at our
disposal, which is not a lot.
Yeah, h6, but that doesn't do much.
I mean, if I were playing black, I
would make some lifts, but that is very advanced.
Yeah, our opponent resigned his last
three games in zero moves.
Okay, that's reassuring.
Okay, let's go rook d1.
Let's double on the d file.
There's no question I'm getting
outplayed for now, but that could change.
Rook f8.
Okay, I fully understand that move.
I guess our opponent is basically
saying that white has no ways to infiltrate.
That's the biggest problem in our
position is that I just can never play
rook d7 because the bishop is guarding
that square.
So basically, white's ability to
improve their position is restricted.
We just have to sit and wait, but if
we're sitting and waiting, I might as
well make some helpful moves.
So one thing I really want to do is
make some lifts for my own king.
We're going to go h3.
We're going to go h3, and this is going
to help in situations where the rooks
start journeying to black side of the
board and etc.
Yeah, I'm apprehensive about this
position, but there's plenty of chess
left to be played.
Plenty of chess left to be played.
Yeah, this guy is playing GM level for
now, but you know, we have reached a
level where people are capable of
playing really, really good chess for
prolonged periods of time.
Maybe not for the entire game.
That would make it a little bit weird,
but for very long periods of time.
Queen e8, knight e4, azumi shook.
This idea is wild.
This might be the first time I've seen
this type of pattern ever.
Okay, but we're playing reasonable moves.
This is going to be a great
advertisement for the jibaba course.
I'm going to lose my first speedrun
game in the jibaba, and that's going to
be the ultimate advertisement for the course.
No, f5 I would love to see.
If he plays f5, I'd be really happy.
The move f5 in this position, it
weakens the bishop tremendously, and
remember that the bishop is what's
holding black's together, because if it
moves, yeah, that's precisely what I
was afraid of.
Okay, I'm getting this feeling of
hopelessness, but we're still going to try.
I'm starting to get that feeling of hopelessness.
I have an idea, which is to play c4.
This was my intended move for a long
time, because I'm trying to push
through b5 and get these pawns rolling
as much as possible.
There's a lot of ways that black can
mess this up.
For example, I think knight e4.
Okay, that's not one of them, but
actually, wait, this move, I thought I
have queen to h4.
I thought I have queen to h4, and I'm
counterattacking the e4 pawn.
I think maybe white is fine here, and
I'm probably miscalculating something.
I'm finally, at least I'm posing some problems.
He's getting a little bit low on time,
although 950 is a lot of time.
Okay, so basically, the idea of queen
h4 is I'm waiting for black to take on
a3, and then I'll play b5, and I'll
attack the knight, and then at the
right moment, I'll play queen takes c4.
I've calculated some nice lines here.
For instance, queen a3 b5.
The good thing is the rooks are doubled.
Otherwise, black would be able to take
on c5, but then we take the knight.
So queen takes a3 b5.
Bang, bang.
Let's say black plays knight to e5.
Then we play queen takes c4, and in
that position, if black plays knight
takes c4, who can tell me what tactical
move I've cooked up as a response?
So queen a3 b5 knight e5, queen e4,
knight c4.
What is my intention?
Yeah, rook e6.
Very good.
Rook takes c6 there because the bishop
is defending the knight on c4, and the
queen is making contact with it.
And if f takes c6, we could even take
the pawn with check first, and then
come back and take the knight.
We'd be up two pawns.
So that's kind of the tactical justification.
There's some other cool lines.
Queen takes a3.
First of all, if black takes the other
way, I don't think he's going to do that.
That would not be a very understandable move.
Okay, queen takes a3.
We play b5.
So I'm trying to play a little bit
quickly here because he took two
minutes on this last move.
If he does that like three more times,
we're in business.
We're totally in business.
So queen takes a3 played.
Now the knight has to decide where it's going.
If black takes on b5, then we take
back, and I'm happy because our pawns
are undoubled.
So if I were playing black, I would
probably move the knight, but this is
an exceedingly complicated position.
This is an exceedingly complicated position.
Okay, he does take, interesting.
So we take back, knight e5.
Okay, I take the pawn.
I take the pawn.
No, I think we're fine now.
I think we're fine now.
I mean, again, the way he's playing,
I'm just, you know, I'm losing some confidence.
After I blundered this knight e4 trick,
I lost some confidence, but I think
we're back in business here.
I think we're back in business.
He has me sweating, that's for sure.
Yeah, so basically now, if queen takes
c5, what do we do in that position?
Because there is a very tempting
tactical move which doesn't work, and
there is a simple move which does.
So what do we do in response to queen c5?
Yeah, we play it simple.
We play queen takes b7.
The tempting move which doesn't work is
actually rook dd5.
I wonder how many of you saw that
possibility, right?
Contact between pieces, always a source
of tactics.
So rook d5, bishop takes d5, rook takes d5.
We're forking the queen and the knight.
Unfortunately, black has a check on c1.
So this is a no -brainer.
We play queen takes b7, and we have now
still two pawns and the rook for the
minor pieces.
Objectively, I would evaluate this as equal.
I think this is close to equal
dynamically, but we have great
practical chances because we have a far
advanced pass pawn, and we have
excellently placed pieces.
And our king is safe.
That really is the main thing, which is
that our king is safe for the time being.
And our goal, well, we have a couple of
things on the horizon.
We are, of course, checking tactics
constantly because rook takes bishop is
possible in certain cases.
Our overarching priority is to push the
pawn, but not if it becomes weaker.
We have to push it very carefully.
And, of course, the third thing to keep
in mind is that a rook trade generally
favors the side with the rook.
So rook to d8 is a possibility.
If black plays knight to c4 in this
position, probably we will respond with
rook to d8 because if black has no
rooks, then stopping the passer is
going to be a lot more difficult.
And the logic is that when your
opponent has only two minor pieces,
minor pieces aren't good at multitasking.
That's what rooks are so good at
because it's a long -range piece.
So if we are to trade a pair of rooks,
then black will have to assign one
minor piece the task of stopping the
pass pawn.
Maybe that'll allow us to transition
the focus to the other side of the
board, if that makes sense.
We are very much in business.
Also, black is getting quite low on the clock.
That's another two minutes our opponent
is spending.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, we actually had a crazy tactic.
There was rook d5, bishop takes d5, and
then queen takes e5.
That led to a draw though.
I think this is our best bet at playing
for a win.
Okay, bishop c8 to me strikes me as a
slightly panicky move.
So the other trade that we would like
to initiate is the trade of queens.
If the queens are traded, it's the same logic.
Black will have a harder time stopping
the passer.
So from that point of view, what move
is on our radar?
So queen b6 is a way to attempt the
queen trade, but it's a little bit
awkward because it puts the queen on
the square where we want the pawn to advance.
So is there another way to offer the
queen trade such that we keep the
coordination of our pieces?
Yeah, queen back to d5.
If you know what you're looking for,
queen d5 should be a reasonable move.
So if black trades, we take back with
even rook 1 takes d5, and b6 is
basically coming next.
So I think this is good for white.
I think queen d5 is a very challenging
move, practically speaking, and black
is down now to five and a half minutes.
Hopefully he takes a little longer
thinking about this.
So I'm already playing a little bit for
the clock here, which I know might
cause some people to roll their eyes.
But again, I'm trying to give you a
sense of how I would normally play.
And if I saw that my opponent was down
to five minutes, I would try to make
moves that pose actual decisions.
Okay, what rook do we take with?
Not an easy question because there's a
tactical detail that has to be factored in.
If we take with rook 1 takes, which I
think is the tempting move, black plays
knight to c4.
And in that position, if we go rook c6,
we fall into bishop b7.
That skewers the two rooks.
So that tells us that after knight c4,
we will have to play rook to d8.
And I did say that a trade of rooks is
good for us.
I'm not totally sure that that holds
true here because the rooks are so
incredibly active.
So from that perspective, rook 6 takes
d5 actually makes some sense because
knight c4 there no longer comes with
tempo, and we can continue harassing
the knight with something like rook c5.
That's a hard question.
It's a very hard question.
Let me think about this for a second.
I do not know what the right call is.
I see a lot of tactics in this line, so
I'm going to go rook 1 takes d5.
But this is purely an intuitive judgment.
I didn't do all that much calculation here.
We're going to take with rook 1.
Knight g6.
Okay, that's a good sign because black
is not stopping us from going b6.
Also, we could of course go rook d8.
That's also a possibility.
But rook d8, is that going anywhere?
Like rook d8 is not going to disappear.
B6 on the other hand, we might not get
another chance to play.
So from that perspective, b6 is good.
What is black going to do after b6?
Well, probably he's going to go bishop
b7, I would imagine.
Then rook can slide over to c5, and we
could try to deploy the rook on the 7th ring.
The downside of that is that black
keeps his rook.
So again, it's a big decision here.
Rook d8.
Yeah, I think from that perspective, we
should go rook d8.
Yeah, I think we should go rook d8.
Because again, b6 is also not going anywhere.
That was the thing I said which was wrong.
Black can't stop b6.
So we take the opportunity while we can
get it.
Now, if black takes on d8, then he
loses the bishop.
But if black plays something like f6,
we don't need to rush.
Rook takes f8, then the rook is not
going anywhere.
We can probably wait until black brings
the king out, and then if necessary,
take on f8.
Bishop b7, okay.
So I guess the move here is rook dd7.
Same logic, right?
A lot of people here would be tempted
to take on f8.
I'm not sure that that's the
appropriate way to play.
Because rushing rook takes f8 helps
black get a piece closer to the queen
side, in this case the king, or even
the knight.
If we play rook takes f8, knight takes
f8, then we can't go rook to d7, which
we would like to play.
So I think rook to d7 is the way to go,
attacking the bishop.
Not immediately.
We're threatening, of course, to take
the rook and then take the bishop.
That's why knight e5 is bad.
No, it does not allow bishop c6 because
the pawn protects that square.
So that's not right.
Now black can take the rook now, and
then block with the knight.
But then we swing the rook over to b8,
we push the pawn from behind, then we
go b6, b7, and once the pawn reaches
b7, if black has a knight on f8, the
rook takes f8 check is going to force
win the game.
Does that make sense?
So actually, this might actually
happen, unless black has found some way
to deal with the pawn.
Okay, let's be very accurate here,
because I think we are on the cusp of
winning this game.
And I think if we want to be ultra
accurate, we should throw in a move here.
Let me think about this.
Okay, so here's what I'm trying to
figure out.
I was trying to figure out whether to
play b6 here, or whether to play this
move, which perhaps was not on
everybody's radar, the move f3.
And the point of f3 is very simple.
I'm trying to force this bishop off
this diagonal so that the red carpet is
unrolled for the pawn.
But the worry that I had after f3 was a
very strange one, it was that black
plays knight to e5, which is an
advanced move, but I'll explain it more
after the game.
But now that I've calculated some
variations, I don't think it's that
dangerous anymore.
So we're going to go f3.
We're going to go f3 and try to knock
the bishop off of this diagonal.
If black plays bishop to a8, then we
play b6, because that bishop on a8 is
incredibly vulnerable.
Okay, knight e5.
Okay, so the reason I wasn't too scared
about this move is that we can
transform our advantage from one to the other.
What does knight e5 do?
Well, it attacks the rook.
And if we move the rook, the main thing
that knight e5 does is it opens up a
retreating square for the bishop back
to b7.
That's really what it does.
So after rook to d4, black is forced to
play bishop b7.
Then I was calculating rook takes f8,
king takes f8.
We can play f4 to chase the knight away.
Knight has to drop back to g6.
Then we move the rook back up to d7.
Bishop b4 is forced, we go b6, and we
win, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure that rook d4 wins by force.
If I've calculated this correctly, rook
d4 wins by force.
But we can also play f takes e4.
I think a lot of you should see this
move, f takes e4.
And after knight takes d7, rook takes
d7, white is up two pawns in that
endgame, the rook endgame.
Mainly we have this passer on b5, so
that should be a win.
But if I've calculated this correctly,
this move wins without a fight, because
we simply force black to give up a
minor for the pawn.
Unless I'm blundering, which is
entirely possible.
Given how the game has transpired so far.
If bishop a8, then we take the rook,
and we put the other rook on d8, and we
pick up the bishop.
If bishop c2, then already we play b6,
and that has to be game over.
Oh crap, he does have bishop f3.
Oh my gosh, I didn't see that.
I didn't see bishop f3.
Man, I'm blundering this game.
A lot of blunders.
He doesn't see it.
Oh, thank god.
Wow, I think bishop f3 might have been
winning, but why risk it?
Yeah, bishop f3 completely escaped my mind.
I didn't practice what I preach.
I didn't notice the forkable squares at all.
This move escaped my attention at all.
Because I just kind of assumed that all
pawn endgames are winning, but somehow
the king in that endgame reaches the
pawn, which is absurd.
Now f4.
Now we play f4, so we chase the knight away.
The knight has only one square.
It only has g6.
Only has g6.
Then we move the rook up to d7 again,
exploiting the fact that the bishop
can't go to the 8th rank because it is forked.
Why are we going rook d7?
To pave the way for the advance of the
pawn, which is finally going to move up
to b6.
We were very patient.
Now I'm very curious to check bishop
f3, because it might actually
relinquish the win, rook d4.
Very sloppy by me.
Very sloppy.
Yeah, that is just inexcusable sloppiness.
Sometimes it just happens.
It happens to everybody, and people
have to realize that.
Sometimes tactically, I'm just slower
on some days than on others.
Okay, now we play b6.
This I calculated correctly because it
shows you how bad minor pieces are at
dealing with the combination of a rook
and a passed pawn.
When you've got a rook and a passed
pawn, black would kill for a rook that
would stop the pawn from b8.
This is kind of why trading rooks often
favors the side with the rook.
King e8, but now a very important detail.
What should we do now?
King e8 is understandable.
Yeah, we play b7, right?
We use the rook, and with its last
gasp, it supports the advance of the pawn.
We promote and we win.
I assume we win this.
I'm not confident in anything, but up a
pawn against two minor pieces, this is
a win.
Actually, I have two examples to show.
Both of them involve minor pieces and
how they work.
I think it'll help you increase your
understanding of how minor pieces
cooperate, and in general, of rook
versus minor piece positions.
Queen e8 and 95, yeah, that idea did
not make it into the course, but we'll
check out how I should have played here.
I mean, clearly white is up a pawn, and
white is much better, but yeah, this
idea escaped me completely.
Okay, so the best way to win such
positions with the corner of your eye,
you double check that there is no way
to win the minor piece.
I don't see any ways to win a minor
piece, so the second best thing is to
go after your opponent's pawns, right?
Again, minor pieces are bad at
defending individual weaknesses, so we
actually lift the queen up to g8.
Careful how you make this move, because
all the surrounding squares like
minesweeper are blocked.
Okay, not a perfect game, but sometimes
that makes it more interesting and more instructive.
Apologies for all the mistakes in this game.
Let's start from the opening.
So first of all, I'm going to pull up
the course just to double check a6, e3,
c5, dc5 was correct, knight c6, and a3.
Very important move.
a3, yeah, e5, bishop g5.
First, we're going to check the game
continuation, then I'll show you a
couple of sidelines.
Bishop e6, b4, bishop e7, knight f3,
castles bishop e2, so the course ends here.
Queen e8 is an incredible move, and
according to the engine, and white is
better here.
White is up a pawn, so we ended the
line here.
Normally, the course ends a lot later
than move 10, but certain situations
where it's clear that one side is
better, and queen e8 is the top move.
Queen e8 is the top move.
It would never occur to me.
Queen e8, rook d8 is an unusual idea,
and castles is indeed a mistake
according to the engine.
Let me tell you what Stockfish15
recommends here.
I'm not going to say never, would never
occur to me.
It is an understandable logical move.
It just comes out of nowhere.
Queen e8, and first of all, to
understand why queen e8 is played, if
black plays knight e4 immediately, then
simply you can play bishop takes e7.
That's why black moves the queen away.
In the game, I couldn't play bishop e7
because of knight takes e3, and there
was a queen that used to stand on d8.
Here, this would work out, but black
takes the bishop with check.
That's the other problem.
If this wasn't a check, you would have
taken the rook on f8, and white would
have been winning, and black would have
been forced then to take on e7 here.
Unfortunately, it's a check, and black
emerges up a piece, so that was the
biggest issue.
The best move here in plus over minus
is knight to a4, which I wanted to play initially.
You actually are supposed to go knight
to a4.
The move that I mentioned before, white
is much better.
It's 0 .7.
Typically, black plays here, and the
idea is simple.
You take the sting out of the move
knight e4.
You castle.
I think most humans would go knight e4 here.
Bishop takes e7.
Queen takes e7, and now a brilliant idea.
If black plays knight takes e7, then
the same idea applies.
So black's biggest advantage in a
position like this is his center, so we
use tactics here to chip away at
black's center.
We make a move that seems brazen but
works concretely.
Let's see if anybody can find it.
What is white's best move in this position?
I've given you a bit of a hint.
Very good.
This chat is on fire.
c4 is the best move.
Very concrete move because you're
giving up a pawn to the discovered
attack, but the idea is to remove the
defender on the knight.
Now the queen goes to c2.
This is not an atypical idea.
I've seen this in other openings.
Black has to defend the knight, and now
you have to be careful how you take on
c4 because now there's an x -ray against
the queen, so the best move of course
is to take with the queen.
Queen takes c4, and notice that the
knight guards d2, so black can still
play this move.
It's the top engine move actually, but
we drop our knight back to c3 to
reinforce the bishop, and black has
basically no compensation here.
For instance, rook f to d8, rook f to d1.
You now neutralize black's last
remaining active piece.
Notice how our control over the d4
square, that's really big here because
that means the knight doesn't have any prospects.
So the biggest takeaway is that after
queen e8, you respond with knight to a4.
A couple of other important lines.
After bishop to g5, a lot of people
here play d4 immediately, including
some GMs.
Here you move the knight out to a4.
This is one of our important
innovations, and if black delivers this
check, then after c3, white is almost winning.
Why is white almost winning here?
Because after d takes c3, there's a
very important move.
If you take back on c3, then black
takes c5, black is all right.
Actually, knight c3, knight e4 is
winning for black.
So you have this intermezzo b4,
connecting the pawns, forcing the queen
away, and if black sacks on b4, as is
all in the course, you simply stop the
pawn with queen c2.
Black loses c3, and black loses the game.
If black moves the queen, then
obviously you can take on f6 first to
ruin the structure and then play knight
c3, and you're much better.
Or the engine even gives this move, and
then you pick up the pawn with the
other knight.
The other knight comes out to pick the pawn.
So queen a5 doesn't work, and this
position is analyzed quite deeply.
After b4, the main move is bishop e7.
If black plays d4 here, then we take on
d4, and if black plays ed4, again we
play knight a4.
And if black tries to chip away at our
pawn chain, we can develop the bishop
and simultaneously pin the knight,
preventing black from taking twice on b4.
A, b, a, b.
And always, we need to develop our
kingside efficiently.
Here, we can just continue developing,
because if black takes, then we take,
and we're up a full pawn.
Again, for no compensation, knight is
threatening to come to b6.
White is clearly better.
This is one of those lines which occurs
ultra, ultra often.
c5 is supposed to play dc, and it's
very hard to come up with a move a3 if
you don't know it.
Some people here will go e6.
Here, simply black is much worse.
After b4, there's no compensation whatsoever.
So e5 is best, but it doesn't solve
black's problems.
If black plays bishop c5, of course,
this is self -evident.
Here, you play bishop takes f6, queen
takes f6.
Well, you can play either queen takes
d5 or knight takes d5.
I think the simplest is knight takes
d5, and then you can support the knight
with c4.
White is up a full pawn.
So certain self -evident things are not
in the course, but most moves that you
need to understand in order to gain a
comprehension of the line are in the course.
So big, big takeaway is queen e8 poses
the threat of knight e4.
That's great to know, but according to
the engine, black is only slightly
better here.
So let's continue looking.
Takes, takes, takes, takes.
Hopefully, it makes sense why you can't
take on f3 here.
You'd lose the piece, so you have to
take the rook, and black takes with tempo.
You have to eliminate the pawn, and we
get this position.
So first rook fd1 is pretty obvious.
I think e4 is an excellent move.
We stuck the rook on d6, and I think
queen e7 is an excellent move as well.
Our opponent is activating his pieces,
and we are doing the same.
Queen h5, preventing queen g5.
h6, another great move.
We respond by bringing our rook in.
So this stage of the game is very understandable.
Rook f8, I think, might be unnecessary though.
I think our opponent should have gone
for our pawns immediately with queen to f6.
I'm not sure rook f8 h3 changes that
much, but surely the lack of a back
rank luft square makes things worse for
us here.
Because here, if we do the same thing
after c4, already black has a slightly
concerning move in knight e5, and black
threatens to take on c4.
And after rook to d4, if black plays
knight takes c4 here, he loses to rook
takes c4.
And this is not mate, because the rook
drops back.
But here, black can go the other way,
knight to g4.
And this is a big problem, because f2
is hanging.
You can't play queen h4.
Obviously, you can't play f3.
So you have to go back with the rook,
but now black gives a check, and black
sticks the queen on b2.
Double attack.
So attacking f2, attacking a3, and if
we bring the rook out, black starts
gobbling up our pawns.
So this waste of a tempo allowed us to
make some luft, and that helps us gain
the upper hand in the complication.
So queen f6 is an excellent move.
I think so is c4.
And here, if black plays knight e5,
already after rook d4, black doesn't
have this move.
That's the key difference.
So it's not only the luft square, it's
the fact that we defend g4 from the knight.
These are the subtleties that often
decide games at this level.
That's just how it works.
So queen f6, we play c4, intending b5.
This is what I was expecting our
opponent to play, and that's actually
what happened.
Sorry.
So we respond with queen h4.
Queen h4 hits the only weakness in
black's position, the e4 pawn.
Queen takes a3 was a serious mistake.
This was an impulsive move by our
opponent, even though it took him two minutes.
I think in this position, black is
still slightly better if he takes this
pawn and simply sticks the bishop on b5.
Why?
Because this immobilizes our pawn chain.
It doesn't allow us to move pawns.
Black is an uncontested light squared
bishop, and he's using it in order to
freeze the pawns.
We would have played probably this
move, and then black would have taken,
and then we would have taken, and then
black would have taken, and the
position remains complicated.
We can even play this move according to
the engine, but this is a bailout move.
c6 here is a bailout move.
If black takes to the bishop, then he
loses queen v4.
But black can also take with a knight,
and the idea is to take and give the
rook back up for the two pieces, and
this is a dead draw.
Like 4 on 3, 1 on 0, this is a dead draw.
So no question that queen a3 was a
serious mistake, because now our pawns
are very, very powerful.
And I think what our opponent missed
from a distance is that after the
trade, and after knight e5 is played,
we take on e4.
I think our opponent forgot that in
this version, black can't play knight
takes c4 because of rook takes c6.
This is what I was talking about.
And after black takes, we take once on
e6, once on c4, and we're up two pawns.
Turns out, according to the engine
though, this is mind -boggling.
There's a better move here than queen
takes c4.
Queen takes c4, queen c5 is still
equal, according to the engine.
Can anybody locate, and if you're
watching on YouTube, you should pause
and try to find this move.
This is a very strong move, which sets
up mating threats.
I didn't see this idea at all.
I mean, I saw it in general, but not here.
Rook d8.
Yeah, rook d6 to d8.
And suddenly, a threatening checkmate.
If black plays queen c5, you play rook
f8, black loses, because king f8, queen d8.
Again, rook trades, when you've got a
rook against minor pieces, are so, so powerful.
Rook d8 traps the queen.
So black has to waste a tempo guarding
the rook on f8, or black has to take.
But now you take with the rook, you
force the king to h7, and now this is a
check, and black starts to lose everything.
So probably black has to reinforce this
rook with a knight, but now you can
play queen e4, and the knight has left
the center.
So if black plays queen c5, you can
play rook f8, knight f8, and queen
takes b7.
This is the chief difference.
Black loses, probably, the game at this point.
If you compare this, if you take
immediately, if you go for this line,
what's the difference?
Here the knight's on e5, so black has
knight takes c4, hitting the rook and
severing the connection with the b5
pawn, so black on the next move can
take, well no, white can play rook a6,
but clearly this is a much inferior
version for white than the one we
looked at with rook d8.
Comparison is a really powerful process
that you can use to understand why
certain moves are played.
In this case, it's to force the knight
off of e5, also to create the
possibility of a rook trade.
Probably a b was another mistake.
I didn't understand why our opponent
did that.
It undoubles our pawns, and after 95,
we still had the move rook to d8,
perhaps, but I think this move makes a
lot of sense here.
Queen c5, queen b7, and white is
playing completely without risk,
because even if white loses the b5
pawn, it's still a draw.
Four on three, and then a rook against
two minor pieces is typically a draw.
So at this point, I want to show two
examples of the battle of rook and
queen versus minor pieces to really
increase your understanding,
particularly of playing with the heavy
pieces, the rook or the queen.
So here's one of my favorite games.
This is not very well known, but it
features a really, really classic
endgame moment.
I'm going to pull up the game in just a moment.
I have to find it on chess space.
This is the game, Mikhalevsky -Kagansky.
Mikhalevsky, very, very strong GM from Israel.
He is also known as a noted chess coach.
He's written opening books, so
definitely a name to revere.
Here he has white against, you know, 2300FM.
Okay, so in this position, it is white
to play, okay?
Okay, so what's going on?
Well, it's clearly two rooks against
two minor pieces and a rook.
First thing that white does is follow
the rules.
White has a very easy clap way to force
the rook trade, and by forcing the rook
trade, white is isolating the minor pieces.
So what does white play?
Oops, sorry.
Mikhalevsky plays rook to c3, rook to c3.
This attacks the bishop, forces the
bishop to move, and now he trades.
So step one has been achieved.
Step two is to make sure that black is
as paralyzed as possible.
So now he brings the other rook to the
8th rank in order to paralyze the knight.
Bishop has to move.
Rook goes back to the 7th rank, and the
bishop moves back to 8th.
Essentially an implicit draw for white
can repeat moves now with rook c8 and
rook c7.
Now there's a move here that I think 90
% of people would play, and then there's
the move Mikhalevsky played, which is
absolutely freaking brilliant.
Okay, obviously black's pieces are very passive.
The move that 90 % of people would play,
probably you're thinking about this
move on YouTube, is rook a7 because,
you know, we see pawns and we take them.
Bishop c6 and rook takes a5.
The downside of this approach is that
it finally opens up a pathway for black
to get his pieces into the game.
So something like knight e6 is now
possible because the knight is no
longer pinned.
Now of course black also attacks d4.
Probably white would now play...
I don't actually know what white does now.
I mean white could play b3 to try to
create a pass pawn on the queen side,
but here black plays knight takes d4,
and clearly you've let black off the hook.
I mean you're not even close to
creating a passer, and black is going
to start bringing his king into the center.
So instead, Mikhalevsky finds a
brilliant move.
Some of you are suggesting rook c5.
It's the same idea.
This move has the same...
I agree.
Rook c5 is better than rook a7 because
here you win the b -pawn, and by winning
the b -pawn you leave black with a
really passive a -pawn.
True, but still black will play, for
instance, let me think, maybe f6, okay,
to open up a pathway for the king.
You will take on f6 and take on b5, and
white is probably winning here.
I agree, but again you've let the minor
pieces get out of their cage, and black
has chances because the minor pieces
get active.
So instead, here's what Mikhalevsky
does, and here's how he arrives at that logic.
Okay, what is black's next move going
to be?
If you gave black the move, how is
black going to untangle?
Well you might say, well black is going
to move the knight, but no, black's not
going to do that because this is a fork.
So in order to be able to move the
knight, black has to get his king off
the eighth rank so that rook c8
wouldn't be a So black's next move is
g6, and that's the only way to untangle.
Now we skip a move, black then plays
king g7, and only then black is ready
to bring the knight out to e6 because
now rook c8 is into check, and the
bishop is able to wiggle out.
So Mikhalevsky finds an idea that
prevents black from ever untangling.
He plays g6 himself and puts the pawn
on pre to three different defenders.
Knight g6, rook c8, we know.
So black takes with the pawn.
Now the second step, you have literally
put a weight on the g6 square, but now
you need to prevent black from going g5
and g6.
White plays f4, stopping g5.
Here, white can even take on g5, but
Mikhalevsky was planning f5, and black
literally can't untangle.
g6, f6, and the king is stuck on the
eighth rank, which means the knight is
stuck on the eighth rank, which means
the bishop is stuck on the eighth rank,
and white can win this pretty easily.
Here's how the game actually ended.
Black starts exhausting his moves, and
here's what Mikhalevsky does.
He literally waits around until black
has exhausted all of his pawn moves,
and look at this position.
Black is in zugzwang.
Black has no moves to avoid losing a
minor piece because either you move the
knight, which is what happened in the
game, and black lost, or you have to
move the king, and you lose to a fork.
If you move the pawn, well, black could
even, white could even take, but f5 is
the elegant move because it really
highlights the extent of white's domination.
So the move was g6, and this is why
piece activity always determines the
evaluation in rook versus minor piece situations.
Here's the second game that I had in
mind, and this is queen against two
minor pieces, which is what we got at
the very end of our game, but I had a
game many years ago that was a lot less
clear -cut than the speedrun game we
played, which was just dead winning.
This is a very old game of mine.
As you can see from 2006, that was
1900, and we reached this very unique endgame.
Queen, two minor pieces, and two pawns
against queen.
This is a very hard endgame to evaluate.
Is this a draw or is this a win for black?
Why are we even discussing this?
White basically has a fortress, right?
White's both pawns are defended by the
bishop and the king respectively, and
black's pawns are gap -toothed, which
means black can't use their pawns to
dislodge white's minor pieces.
You need to find some other way.
Let's flip it so we're facing black.
What I started to do earlier in the
game is I brought my king to white's
side of the board, and I didn't know
exactly how that was going to help, but
I thought that might be a good start.
For a while, I was unable to make any
progress, and I was unable to make
progress for so long, and this is a
draw that I ultimately gave up hope.
I was hoping to deliver some made, but
my opponent just correctly shuffles the
pieces, but then at some point, we
repeat and repeat and repeat.
At some point here, my opponent makes a
very sloppy move.
He plays king f3.
He should have played king to f1, so he
lets my queen into e1.
The king hides away on g2.
Okay, then I played king to d2, and now
things are getting serious.
It's still a draw, but white can play
bishop f5, make a draw, but my opponent
was worried about king e2.
He forgot that the bishop can just come
back to g4, and this is a dead draw.
Black literally cannot get to the f2 pawn.
Hopefully, that makes sense, but he
plays bishop g4 to d1 and offers a
draw, and I suddenly got scared.
I was like, wait, the queen is trapped,
and I took a draw.
Bishop d1 is a losing move.
Who can tell me why, and I analyzed
this for a long time with my coach.
We came up with some very cool lines here.
As far as we know, this is analysis
from 2005.
This is a loss.
No, the mot point is queen takes d1.
Remember from the pawn endgame videos,
it's not about whose king is more advanced.
It's about whose king is closer to the pawns.
If you think of it that way, you should
understand that white's king is very
close to the h4 pawn.
This is not going to be winning.
This is probably a draw, but I think
even black is close to losing this
because this type of, okay, it's a draw.
It's a draw, but black draws by like
narrow thread.
It's not queen takes d1, and it's not
queen takes d3, similar reasoning.
Black -white is going to be the first to
take the pawn, so this is not the right approach.
Instead, you have to notice that the
bishop on d1 is very vulnerable because
it's protected by the knight.
The move is f5.
Yeah, f5.
How does that f5 help?
Because the bishop, of course, can go
back, let's say, to f3.
Now, as far as I remember, you're
supposed to play f4.
You're supposed to play f4.
White has basically two options.
Where is white going to go with his knight?
Well, probably white is going to go to
g4 because if white goes elsewhere, the
pawn on f2 can be surrounded.
You can go like this, and then white is
almost in zugzwang because white has no moves.
White has to go back with his king.
You can deliver a check on a1, and
basically the bottom line idea is you
like go here, and you're trying to go
king e1.
You're trying to set up this situation
where the pawn cannot be defended.
White can only stop you in one way to
go king f1, and who can find the most
accurate move in this position?
Let's see who understands how this
endgame works.
Black has a winning move here.
How do you clear the way for the king?
There's only one correct check.
Peter Perturb got it.
It's queen to c4 check because you have
to keep the f4 pawn protected.
Then you drive your king into e1.
White is in zugzwang.
White has no pieces to move other than
his king, and now queen f1 is just game over.
Okay, so this is winning.
That means that white has to sit on g4
because on g4, the knight is
unassailable, and it's defending f2,
but I'm pretty sure the black is still
winning here.
How is black winning here?
Let me try to remember.
Or is he winning?
Yes, black is winning because I think
what you're supposed to do here, you
start with a move like queen a1, okay?
So white has to make some random bishop move.
You get in with your king, but then you
make this very important move.
Here you play like queen to a6, I think.
I don't remember how this wins.
Maybe this is a draw.
Maybe we were wrong.
Let me check the engine.
Let me check the engine here.
This is interesting.
f5, but by the way, it shows you how
resilient minor pieces are at holding
things together.
It's like very, very hard to crack these.
Yeah, it is winning.
It is winning.
Bishop f3.
Oh, f4 is wrong.
I apologize.
f4 is not the move.
The move is queen to b1, and basically,
white loses.
So white makes a random bishop move,
and now you play king to e1, and if
white makes a random bishop move, oh,
you just pick up the pawn on f2.
You don't need to play f4.
What am I saying?
Of course, f4 is useless because
ultimately, you're going to push white
off the board.
Check here, here, and that's it.
You're threatening checkmate on g1, so
white has to move the knight and give
up the pawn on f2, and there's just
nothing that white can do.
You just get in.
You get into e1 with the king.
White has just no other moves.
If white gives the check, then you get
in anyway, and now you go queen b2.
You attack the pawn.
White's knight is no checks, like the
king can't be assailed, and then you do
this thing where you go king to queen
g7, and then king f1 to push the king away.
It's a cool idea, but I didn't see any
of that, and you couldn't do that earlier.
Like here, if white waits around with
any move other than bishop f1, it's
harder to get the king in because,
okay, you can go queen c1.
You can go here, but there is, I think,
ah, the point is white can go like king
g1, and then at the right moment,
knight g2 check.
So somehow here, white holds, but with
a pawn on f5, black takes away key
squares from the bishop and the knight.
Okay, let's move on to the game.
Hopefully, this was semi -illuminating.
It just came to my mind because I
remember the two minor pieces.
So in the game, once we played queen
b7, I could sense that we were close to winning.
Then we initiated the forced queen
trade, and knight g6 is another mistake.
This is a very, very bad move because
now the knight is passive.
Black has to go knight c4.
There's no question that the knight has
to keep contact with the b6 square.
What I was talking about is this would
be very careless because of bishop b7,
and black wins an exchange.
Now, I want to point something out,
which is that if white's pawn was on
e4, if you had this position, this
would be fine for white.
So don't forget that if you have rook
versus two minor pieces, you can gain
the minor pieces again for the rook.
So don't rule out lines where you lose
your rook if you win both minor pieces.
Of course, here we don't have the pawn
on e4, so that doesn't work.
So after knight g6, rook d8, okay, the
game is over.
But now, of course, I made a horrible mistake.
f3 is correct, knight e5 is correct.
Yeah, rook d4 is a big mistake.
It's still winning after bishop f3,
still winning.
But the best move was just to take the
rook and go rook c7, and then promote
the pawn.
I don't understand why I didn't play
this, but this ends the game immediately.
Yeah, rook f8 and rook c7, I don't know.
I was somehow fixated on forcing black
to be the one to take because I was
obsessed with the idea of forcing the
king in the other direction.
Somehow, I didn't, like, realize that
the king is still too far away from the pawn.
But rook d4 would win if it weren't for
bishop f3.
Apparently, the winning move here, the
only winning move, and let me explain
why the pawn endgame is drawn.
The reason the pawn endgame is drawn,
first of all, is because the king
catches the b -pawn.
So you have the gap -toothed pawn
formation, which is self -sufficient.
The king can't take either of the pawns.
That's fine.
So you get this situation, black's king
has to shuffle between d7 and d6.
The problem is that black is a three -on
-one on the queen side, and white cannot
defeat a three -on -one with his king alone.
Like, black will play here, and then
here, and you have no way, even like
f4, you have no way to make progress
because this is a protected passed pawn.
Does that make sense?
So this is just a dead -drawn pawn endgame.
The move, apparently, is e4.
You have to cut off the bishop.
You have to cut off the bishop, and on
the next move, you play b6.
Bishop e2?
Actually, no.
Apparently, you throw in rook d5 first
to hit the knight.
Now you play b6.
Okay, so you're threatening b7.
Okay, so black has to stop the pawn.
Now you deliver a check.
You go around to a8.
Oh, wow, and black can't go here
because of rook a7.
Beautiful.
So you're forcing the bishop away, and
now you promote to a pawn.
You force black to give up his knight.
By the way, I see this mistake so often.
If black plays knight c6 here, who can
tell me what the best move is for white?
Is it to promote the pawn?
This is a mistake I see very, very often.
Rook c8, yeah.
Rook c8 wins on the spot because you
actually give up the rook for the
knight, and you promote to a queen.
So don't automatically promote when
your opponent is stopping the minor
pawn, the pawn to the minor piece.
See if you can essentially capture the
minor piece because then you can
promote the entire pawn.
After knight d7, black, white doesn't
have the same option because the knight
can't be a sale, but this is winning.
This is theoretically winning endgame,
but some work would still be required
for us to win this, and definitely
there was not need to blunder this.
These can be very, very hard to win.
Like 3 -on -3 can be very, very, very
hard to win.
So definitely this should not have been allowed.
You want to hear something crazy?
So do you remember I said you throw in
this move?
Why not b6 immediately?
Here's the difference.
So here you've got the same line, rook a8.
Black plays bishop d, sorry, black
plays, no, here apparently black plays
some sort of weird king e7.
Oh, and if you start with rook d5, in
this position, there is no king e7
because here you can take the knight
and play b7.
So you're forcing bishop a6, whereas
there, there's some tricky king e7 move.
So many of these subtleties, these
types of positions, amazing.
Just as honestly amazing.
Okay, after our opponent played bishop
b7, the only critical move was f4,
forcing the knight away.
Look at the domination, c6 controlled,
d7 controlled, c4 controlled.
The knight has to drop all the way back
and bang, rook d7, again, domination.
Bishop can't go back to the 8th, and we
go, we'll go b6, and b7 is going to decide.
Knight e7, rook d8 is checkmate, by the way.
Don't forget this mating pattern.
Even with a king on f8, it's still
possible to back rank mate.
King e8, b7, and that's it.
b8 queen is happening.
Of course, this is technically
nominally more resilient, but four on
three plus an extra exchange is easy win.
You just get your king up, and then you
basically just push your pawns to oblivion.
This is super, super straightforward
winning process here.
Okay, so takeaways from this really
excellent game.
First of all, a huge kudos to our
opponent for finding this queen e8,
knight e4 idea.
So the opening was a jabava line, and I
want to remind people I have a course
on this opening that will be linked in
the description that I released
together with GM Alexander Bortnik.
So this follows the course.
This all follows the course.
My biggest mistake was not to ask what
my opponent wanted with this move.
In fact, I asked what he wanted.
I thought he wanted rook d8.
So the correct move here is to
preemptively move the knight away from
an undefended square and to take the
sting out of the move, knight e4.
That would have given white a clearly
better position.
Instead, once we blundered the two
pieces for a rook, black was better,
but we did our best to activate our pieces.
We found resilient moves all the way through.
And the critical mistake for black,
black made a couple of mistakes.
First of all, rook f8 was a waste of time.
The immediate queen f6 would have been
very problematic for us.
This allowed us to make loft, and then
the main mistake that black played is
to take the pawn on a3.
Black should have taken the other pawn.
When you have the minor pieces against
a rook, your top priority should
basically be to hold off your
opponent's pawn mass.
Because once the pawn mass starts
rolling, rooks are really, really good
at supervising past pawns.
So you want to keep things immobilized
as much as possible.
Any questions?